>>> TED CRUZ IS MIXING
BASKETBALL AND POLITICS AGAIN,
AND GETTING MOCKED FOR DOING SO
AGAIN.
BACK IN 2016 IN BASKETBALL CRAZY
INDIANA OF OWL PLACES, CRUZ
CALLED THE BASKETBALL RIM THE
RING, YEAH, HE CALLED THE RIM
THE RING.
THIS TIME IT'S A MUCH MORE
SERIOUS ISSUE.
THE TEXAS SENATOR YESTERDAY
TWEETING SUPPORT FOR NBA PLAYERS
WHO REFUSE TO GET THE COVID
VACCINE.
YOU CAN SEE THEM RIGHT HERE.
I STAND WITH KYRIE IRVING.
I STAND WITH ANDREW WIGGINS AND
BRADLEY BEAL.
I STABBED WITH JONATHAN ISAAC
AND THEN ADDING THE HASHTAG YOUR
BOLD, YOUR CHOICE.
CRUZ HASN'T HAULS BEEN SO QUICK
TO STAND WITH NBA PLAYERS.
HE WAS HARDLY CRITICAL OF NBA
PLAYERS WHO SUPPORTED NFL
PLAYERS WHO STILL TAKE A KNEE
PROTESTING POLICE BRUTALITY OR
OTHER CAUSES.
TO ALL THE ATHLETES WHO HAVE
MADE MILLIONS IN AMERICAN
FREEDOM, STOP INSULTING OUR
HEROES.
NEVER BUY ANOTHER SHIRT, SHOES
OR JERSEY FROM RICH ATHLETES
WHOSE MISSION IS TO DISPARAGE
THE FLAG.
NBA ATHLETES WHO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE NFL ATHLETES.
THERE ARE CONSERVATIVES LIKE
SENATOR CRUZ WHO SAY GOVERNMENT
MANDATES FOR VACCINES ARE WRONG.
IT'S A POSITION THAT YOU CAN
MAKE IN TODAY'S POLITICS, BUT TO
JUMP OUT AT A TIME VACCINATION
IS CRITICAL, PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS ARE SAYING TO BACK THESE
ATHLETES.
NUMBER ONE IT'S A PLAY FOR
PUBLICITY, OPPORTUNISM.
NUMBER TWO, IT'S WHAT?
>> A PLAY FOR OPPORTUNITY AND
FOR THE BASE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THERE'S A BIG DEBATE EARLIER
ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL,
$3.5 TRILLION IN SPENDING AND
THE ENERGY OF THE PARTY IS VEALY
ON THE SOCIAL ISSUES, ON THINGS
LIKE VACCINES AND THINGS LIKE
VOTING RIGHTS AND, YOU KNOW,
SENATOR CRUZ WANTS TO BE PART OF
THE MIX.
YOU WOULD THINK MAYBE HE'D NOT
WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN ANY TALK
ABOUT BASKETBALL AFTER 2016 BUT
SAW THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BACK IN AND PROVE HIS BONA FIDES
TO THE TRUMP BASE SAYING I'M NOT
IN SUPPORT OF, YOU KNOW, THESE
VACCINE MANDATES AND ALL OF THIS
GOVERNMENT CONTROL AND IT SEEMS
LIKE HE'S LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO INJECT HIMSELF
AHEAD OF 2024 TO SHOW THAT HE'S
STILL THE CONSERVATIVE THAT
VOTERS MAY HAVE THOUGHT HE WAS,
YOU KNOW, SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
NOW HE'S TRYING TO CLAIM THAT
TITLE.
>> THE KEY POINT IS THE
REPUBLICAN BASE, THE TRUMP PART
OF THE REPUBLICAN BASE WHICH IS
A BIG PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
BASE.
NATIONAL SURVEYS WOULD SHOW YOU
THAT THE MANDATES HAVE SUPPORT.
MANDATES FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, MANDATES FOR TEACHERS
GETS A LITTLE MORE EVEN WHEN YOU
SAY MANDATES FOR PRIVATE PLOYS,
A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A DIVIDE
BUT HE'S DECIDED THIS IS A PLAY
FOR THE TOTAL 2024 OR WHATEVER
PLAY FOR THE REPUBLICAN BASE.
>> IT -- THERE IS A COMPONENT OF
THIS BASE THAT ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVES THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TELL YOU WHAT TO DO, AND
THERE'S TWO WAYS TO LOOK AT THE
MANDATE.
SHOULD THE GOVERNMENT FORCE
PEOPLE TO PUT A NEEDLE IN THEIR
HARMS?
THAT'S ONE QUESTION.
CAN EMPLOYERS AND TEAM OWNERS
AND LARGE VENUES A